[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today today's
question comes from Billy in Indiana 10
years ago I was destitute and owed
$15,000 to the IRS I raised my kids by
myself with no contribution from my
ex-wife I followed your teachings and
I'm now debt-free with money in savings
and Investments I'm retired and living
very frugally but I'm terrified of being
destitute again my weekly grocery budget
is am I reading this right
$35 I don't use the AC in the summer and
won't turn on the heat in the winter
this is from Billy in
Indiana uh he turns it on when it gets
below freezing yikes I've taken all the
light bulbs but one out of all the
fixtures in the house I take three
minute showers and haven't eaten out in
two years how do I live without my
phobia of being broke again man this is
intense but I but let me just say
destitute it's a heavy word the kids
youngers don't know what that word means
but that takes down and out to a new
level and I think that um him having
nothing at all so seared his conscience
yeah I mean this is as much emotional
relational as it is financial I do and I
think therapy I think this is some I
think I would get some therapy on this
to be able to create a
narrative that
is
uh in opposition to the voice of fear
because the voice of fear is rooted in
tremendous pain George and so you've got
to counteract that this again delone is
not here but the bottom line is this is
a form of
OCD and and OCD is anxiety and I'm not
in any way diagnosing him with OCD but
I'm saying it feels like he's so
obsessed with saving money that you're
talking about 35
not using the Airing I've seen this
episode of extreme cheap skates these
people do not have thrilling joyful
lives they're terrified they're
terrified and so I would start with I
think Ken spot on here uh Billy you need
to go to therapy and deal with the past
and a good start is reading our friend
Dr John delon's book own your past
change your future because you're not
there anymore you're doing well now and
so we tell people to make a budget and
actually look at how much margin you
have and force yourself to go out and
eat once a week force yourself to go be
generous we found that generosity can
unlock something when it comes to that
destitute mindset and it will make you
have an open hand when it comes to money
so I would start to give save spend in
each area you're great at saving and
that muscle has been flexed but you got
a flat tire when it comes to giving and
spending so I would increase both of
those force it in your budget and the
other thing I would do is get people
around you you sound like you're
isolated like you're living like a
recluse
start making some Community get plugged
into a local church hang out with family
and friends that's going to help you
break out of this yeah I agree I mean
this is just overcoming the trauma and
then beginning to uh get the tools to
get over it but then then you got to
take some steps and go okay what if what
if I spend $150 a week on groceries is
it going to tank you no can you but but
I think the fear is so great here that
even seeing it on paper I don't know
that that's going to solve it stair stpp
it we're going to spend 40 bucks this
week 45 the next week until you're
spending a reasonable amount I mean this
sounds like it's affecting your health
if you're living in a 34 Dee house
eating literal rice and beans that's
frightening so uh Billy we're we're
wishing you the best man but you got to
take some steps to knock yourself out of
this Vortex sorry to hear you going
through that create your free every
dollar budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life